coming off of a stellar season under his
watch along with Tom Coughlin two guys
from the Bill Parcells coaching tree the
head coach the Jacksonville Jaguars Doug
Marrone here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you coach rich I'm doing great you
know we just got done coming off the
field on OTA and you know it's kind of
kind of tough and rough and then you
know the intro got me going I'm ready to
go you ready hey you know what coach
people say that they want to run through
walls for me so I understand what you're
saying
exactly exactly what's your what's your
favorite Parcells story coach I'd love
to I love to hear them from somebody
around oh no I didn't think you know
I've met with coach Parcells and you
know just trying to get insight and you
know learn how to be a better head coach
and things of that nature and you know I
learned I learned that when when coach
has it and he says I got it that means
it's time for you to shut your mouth
I'll start a story out say coach you
know how would you handle this and I go
on to it he goes I got it and and it's
the cutest shot your mouth and just
listen how long did it take you to learn
that though pretty quickly because I you
know I I'm one of those people I think
that you know I went there to gain
information a lot of times when people
try to get information sometimes they
wanted up talking too much I just try to
you know just ask the question and
really listen I think that you know some
it's a trait that I was fortunate you
know my parents brought me up that way
you know God gave you one mouth in two
years to listen twice as much as you
talk I kind of learned that and it
helped me with you know some of the
coaches that have been through this for
a long time and you know I've learned a
lot by just keeping my mouth shut and
listening now that said coach you have
quite a locker room filled with alpha
males down there I mean you're telling
me so how do you instill that and such a
young diet again young dynamic I heard
that you guys exemplify that in the NFL
and an alpha males like Jail and Ramsey
just obviously for one how do you
instill that sensibility in your locker
room you know Richard it's tough and
challenging from a standpoint
you know the way that you know you know
maybe yourself or myself the way we were
raised in a profession or in guys that
or coaches that we played for or you
know when I first got started the league
and I think that you know when I left in
the whirling Saints to go back to
Syracuse to take the head job there you
know then I went back out into the
communities in the homes of a lot of
these young men and just realize that
you know what social media and things
you know things are different and I
think it's a fine line of letting your
players be who they are at the same
point you know making sure that we do
have team chemistry and and that team
comes first so you know basically trying
to you know manage that situation is
something I think you know all of us are
challenged with in this day and age this
does last year's sit down of Leonard
fournette fall in that category um that
that's kind of what you know my past has
been and and you know just you know just
you know trying to make sure that the
rules apply to everyone again it was an
unfortunate incident and you know one
that we all can learn from including
myself you know I'm continuously
learning but uh I got a funny story for
you so go for it one of the players that
you mentioned before you know it come
out and said something you know publicly
and you know kind of bulletin board
material and so I just you know I bring
him in and I say you know hey listen
what about those comments how do you
feel it's like well you know coach I was
just so fired up and you know I just
felt like saying that and I just how I
feel and you know maybe I still may be
it's something that you know I shouldn't
have said but it just came out of my
mouth and then all the sudden goes but
you know what coach you know the way I
look at it you probably want to say it
and you can't because you're the head
coach so I'm singing it for you so we
turn that around on me like that but you
know it's one of those things I think
it's a fine line you're always trying to
educate you know but at the same the
same sense you you don't want like you
said we've got a lot of talented kids
you know you don't want to you know
limit their their expression you're
talking so Jalen Ramsey is your de facto
I'm not mentioning any names they're
rich these days he's your new spokesman
for the chance I know that's what you
thinking I said yeah
I'm thinking that come on no I you know
and and you know what we have to learn
that time to embrace that as a team if
someone says something or someone
believes in something then you know
we're all accountable to you know you
don't back that player up and and that's
something I think I try to find a
positive whereas I think a lot of times
you know some people see a negative in
it so Doug Marrone Jacksonville Jaguars
head coach here in the Rich Eisen show I
did think of you and Tom Coughlin after
those Ramsay comments prior to the AFC
Championship game all fired up coming
back from Pittsburgh I really did think
of you two guys and what what you were
gonna say to him after all that and then
obviously everything was copacetic going
into that game because of how well you
you played in New England how often do
you play back that AFC championship game
in your head driving at work or just
staring up at the ceiling or any any
moment and time cuz I mean you know it's
it's so difficult for me you know
sometimes they have those replays on TV
and you know I just you know I get
frustrated with myself because I think
you know I look at myself and say you
know what could I have done a better job
for our team you know how can I put them
in better position you know what could I
could have done you know what maybe I
could have done differently and I think
you know it's a it's a point it's it's
an issue that's that's in our all of our
stomachs you know it's tough I mean just
mention it and you feel that same type
of pain you know that you felt
afterwards but I think it's important
especially for this team like you said
you know there's talent here you know it
is a young football team and we'll think
of you know the one challenge that we
have is you know we're not that team
that we were at the end of the year
where we were playing you know we've got
to go back and learn lessons from the
past but let's make sure we learn a
lesson of how hard we worked at this
time of year in training camp and during
the season and that's what's going to
get us to a position that we hope you
know where we can you know win us AFC
South and and and move on but there's a
lot of work to be done in between so
what what what do you look back and
thinking you could change or wish was
different other no I mean there's a lot
of things you know from an aggressive
style it is there's so many things that
you'll question and not just because it
was the AFC Championship game I think
you know I did it to myself after every
game when you you know win or lose for
me is difficult because I've only
saying I always think that you know we
could have done a better job yeah you
know and and I have a hard time with the
way I'm wired of you know really
appreciate it appreciating it and I have
to force myself you know to make sure
that I do a good job can graduate the
players to do a good job and you know I
know that you know when they don't they
obviously you know they're gonna hear
from me and when I don't do a good job I
think it's important to being that coach
to stand up there and say hey listen you
know I've got to do a better job and it
starts with me
well in terms of that game coach I'd
love to give you a chance to respond
because so many people were saying the
way that the play calling went down at
the end of the first half of that game
was indicative of the confidence you
have in your quarterback and Blake
bortles in trying to win a football game
and not trusting him or something along
those lines how do you respond to that
well I respond to it this way I mean we
go into the game with a plan prior to I
don't think it's a matter of you know
the trust or what you want to do I do
have a history of playing against that
team the one up you know know anyone
that we're speaking about I've done it a
couple of different ways I just felt
that you know I think the critical point
was you know after the timeout you know
the clock ran quick and we wound up you
know getting a complete pass were in
scoring position and then wound up being
nullified with the delay a game you know
that hurt us and you know you had to
lead you wanted to go in you wanted to
make sure that we were in good shape
after we we made that mistake and then
coming out we felt like we were when we
did a good job early on with our run
play action game and felt that we really
needed to run the football and get that
going and we just didn't do a good
enough job of that well so how is
bortles a different quarterback if at
all from when you first found him so far
no well you know you know the first time
really putting in the system was was the
two games or it really I think it was
three or four games with which coach
Hackett and it's difficult when you're
you know you're trying to implement a
system but there's a system already in
place so you know last year was the
first time that that we you know we had
the full system in place with them and
you know early on and training camp
obviously there were some struggles and
he's really really came back from that
you know he's a resilient kid probably
the greatest characteristic is his
toughness and and and
and being able to handle you know all
the noise on the outside and then really
probably around from the Cincinnati game
on he really sits on you know getting
confidence in the system that there's
teammates getting a lot of confidence in
them and you know we've always felt that
he has the ability to do it and he
really started to play well and in year
two the way we started out now you know
he has a very good grasp when we're
expecting obviously better better better
things from him this year a couple more
minutes left with Doug Marrone head
coach the Jacksonville Jaguars here on
the Rich Eisen show how far can this
team go coach well I'll tell you what if
we don't do a good job right now
creating this foundation you know it's
gonna be tough to go far at all and I
think that's the most important thing
and one we've been driving home with the
players you know about our communication
and you know our team chemistry and and
our discipline and structure of how we
want to get things done how we want to
look when we turn the tape on you know
that's the other thing if you said you
know what have you learned from coach
Parcells is that you never start off you
know where you left off you always have
to start from the beginning and that's
been a big thing that we've been
preaching preaching to our players of
creating this foundation of hard work
and what we want to be you know by
what's on that tape so you know it's
it's a challenge and it's one we're
working through each and every day to
make sure that we put on the tape what
we want all right now how would Jalen
Ramsey answer that question are you
ready to go how would he answer the
question about how far you can go coach
how do you think he'd answer it I can't
speak for Jalen you're not gonna speak
for me but you know again he's you know
he's you know I know that he's you know
he's not here with us now but you know
we keep in touch and he's working
extremely hard and he's looking forward
to you know an outstanding year alright
coach and a woman's the last time you
spoke with Jail and I know he's not
there right now LTS I touch base with
him each week you know and you know
there's enough stuff with him online and
working with his dad so you know we know
he's working hard and you know is what's
expected of him when he gets here all
right coach you take care of yourself I
love our chat let's let's do it again
real soon no problem race thank you for
having me on you guys you got stuck
Marone the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience